[Music]
we knew they were going to try
everything to try to get donald trump
reelected
and the next step is sabotaging the post
office
and this is super important to know
about so
yes donald trump floated yesterday the
idea of delaying the presidential
election
unlikely to happen he doesn't actually
have the power to do it
he can mess up the post office pretty
badly and that's what he's trying next
so to set this up
coronavirus hits but we know we have an
election coming up in november okay
simple solution you vote by mail and
when we say vote by mail we don't mean
some new system we just mean expanding
absentee ballot access to anybody that
wants an absentee ballot
whether or not coronavirus is under
control in november
we don't know it's increasingly looking
like it's going to be out of control
but we expand absentee ballot access to
everybody we've got a solution for a
safe election
trump is against it trump is against it
because he says there will be fraud
trump doesn't understand that vote by
mail is the same
in this case as just absentee we're not
talking about a different system he's
either confused
or he's lying or he's distorting or
whatever we don't know
will governors mostly fortunately take
matters into their own hands and they
expand absentee ballots
they in some states say everybody can
get one
in others they say you still have to
have a valid reason for requesting an
absentee ballot
but fear of catching coronavirus counts
as a valid reason
some states are doing other types of
expansions but for the most part
governors do the right things so what is
trump's next move
well he's trying to neuter and kneecap
the post office donald trump has
appointed louis de joy to be postmaster
general
de joy just happens to be a huge trump
donor who
wants to see donald trump re-elected and
dejoy has announced
that he's going to eliminate overtime
for hundreds of thousands of postal
workers
over time widely expected to be needed
as we have a record number of people
opting to vote absentee rather than in
person
which could delay mail services and of
course prevent the
delivery of the ballots in other words
trump
through his postmaster general is trying
to cause the very problems
that he cited as the reason why we
shouldn't have vote by mail
louis de joy is also considering closing
a bunch of post offices
across the country and the joy is using
kind of coded language to try to hide
his intentions saying things like well
listen
we haven't done any kind of reform in
the post office for a long time we're
going to take a fresh
look at the operations of the postal
service this is all code now
we know that because of coronavirus and
because we know that absentee ballot
access
has been expanded in a bunch of states
around the country
there will be way more absentee ballots
this year than arguably in any prior
year
and we are just a few weeks from the
start of that remember four and a half
weeks from now
some states start voting absentee so
what do they want to do
cut the post office this is completely
obvious
three months before an election trump
puts in a big donor
to run the post office and immediately
trump's donor says whoa whoa stop the
clock let's reduce mail service
what people are emailing me saying how
is this legal that's a great question
this is extremely authoritarian
something we're now used to with donald
trump
this is another example of regulatory
capture
and this is another example of the right
wanting to suppress
turnout if you can't stop people from
going to the polls as easily
because lots of people are going to be
voting by mail prevent their ballots
from being delivered
by hurting the post office this is the
strategy
and it should be mentioned you know
sometimes i point out
democrats and republicans are both part
of
maintaining this status quo or they're
both
mostly on board with expanding the
military budget or whatever
this is not a both sides issue for is it
20 years is it longer
the right has had the strategy of trying
to hold down turnout
in certain areas to try to win elections
the left doesn't do this
the left doesn't consider as a top
strategy for winning elections let's
figure out how to prevent people from
voting
or how to prevent people's votes from
counting so first of all
number one we have to so overwhelm the
vote that these strategies won't work
i've been saying that for a year uh or
longer and
i hope that now everybody understands
why it's true secondly
there is a maybe possible backfire
effect here so
right now red states have been way more
hit by coronavirus than blue states
for now this could mean that red states
are doing more online shopping because
it's safer to go shopping in blue states
than red states
and so hurting the postal service might
actually
anger more republicans than democrats
now
whether they'll link it to trump's
postmaster and hold trump accountable is
another story remember that
when obamacare passed and republican
governors
opted not to do the medicaid expansion a
lot of those red state voters
blamed obama even though obama gave the
governors the tools it was the governors
who opted not to do it
they may not actually hold the right
people accountable but they are doing it
they're doing it right now this is not a
dress rehearsal
and that is almost going to be the
everybody must vote
and this is not a dress rehearsal or
very quickly becoming the phrases of the
next three months
if you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much
i love my helix mattress well i was
really excited to hear that helix has
launched a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you twenty percent off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put
in my living room at home it's now my
favorite piece of furniture
in the house it took me just minutes to
set it up it's solidly built it's
huge it's roomy it has a modern
minimalist design which i love but it's
also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality it has become the
focal point of my living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new
sofa or chair you get 100 days to decide
if you want to keep it and the best part
is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now and get
20 off your entire order when you get
there
by going to all form.com pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video